[Music]  they're here for me  [Applause]  special agent justin rosa here for wire  room duty do you know what a wire room  is it's a lawful interception of  conversations of subjects under criminal  investigation  it's a gun smuggling case with the  cartel  this is our guy  eddie flynn  we tracked a few of their shipments but  it's been quiet here ever since  maybe you'll get some actual activity  what could go wrong  calm down a junior someone's called me  where are you  there's one right outside your door he's  coming your way  the target of our investigation is under  attack you called eddie didn't you said  to keep him alive i was wrong you are a  complete idiot  i talked to the sheriff's department why  would you do that don't you dare move  not till i get there  what have you gotten into dirty cops are  everywhere  guessing they're coming for you  what's it feel like what does what i  feel like knowing everyone wants to kill  [Applause]  they have you idea what's coming  you